bonsoir à tous ça vous regarde en direct
soyez les bienvenus notre grand témoin
ce soir vous la reconnaissez c'est
Isabelle Lasserre bonsoir Isabelle
bonsoir et merci infiniment d'être là
dans le fauteuil du grand témoin vous
publiez Macron Poutine aux éditions de
l'Observatoire les liaisons dangereuses
on va revenir ce titre et sur le livre
en longueur tout à l'heure beaucoup
d'actualités sur le front ukrainien la
contre-offensive de Kiev se prépare et
on est au lendemain d'une drôle
d'annonce de Moscou du nataque présumée
de drone sur le Kremlin on va y revenir
également mais on commence ce soir par
débattre de la crise du logement c'est
un cri d'alarme que pousse tous les
acteurs du secteur le logement subit un
choc très violent avec la hausse des
taux d'intérêt pour contrer l'inflation
effondrement de l'accès à la propriété
marcher locatif complètement bloqué les
députés s'empare du sujet en s'attaquant
notamment à Airbnb on en parle dans un
instant sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver à 20h15 nos parties pris nos
affranchis et puis d'un Bourbon Express
ce soir la victoire des communistes sur
les soignants non vaccinés c'était à
l'Assemblée aujourd'hui voilà pour le
menu vous me suivez cher Isabelle et
bien ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est le premier poste de dépenses des
Français alerte rouge sur le logement la
crise ne date pas d'hier mais la
situation devient aujourd'hui
catastrophique les acteurs par le même
d'une bombe à retardement social et
accuse les politiques de déni bonsoir
Julien Bayou bonsoir et merci beaucoup
d'être là vous êtes députés européens
Écologie Les Verts de Paris et vous
faites partie de ces parlementaires qui
ont lancé un appel transpartisan pour
encadrer les locations touristes
touristiques qui explosent notamment à
Paris mais pas seulement grâce aux
plateformes comme Airbnb bonsoir ignaki
et chemise bonsoir merci vous aussi vous
en êtes de cet appel les locations
Airbnb de courte durée elles foisonnent
dans votre département le beau Pays
Basque puisque vous êtes député
socialiste des Pyrénées-Atlantiques je
précise que évidemment Renaissance a été
invité ce soir mais malheureusement
anaiglemort a eu un empêchement bonsoir
Xavier demozoir et merci d'être là
maître demeuse voix vous êtes av entre
autres de la plateforme Airbnb
avocat au barreau de Paris et on a
compris vous connaissez bien ces
contentieux parce qu'il y en a entre
entre les
propriétaires et parfois les
collectivités locales bonsoir Stéphane
imovitz et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes le président du choris c'est une
entreprise de conseil en immobilier pour
les investites d'investisseurs
institutionnels alors évidemment c'est
pas votre sujet Isabelle on connaît vos
chroniques internationales dans cette
émission mais c'est un sujet extrêmement
concernant donc la citoyenne que vous
êtes n'hésitez pas à réagir on a des
enfants et c'est galère tous à trouver
un logement en location on va commencer
par planter le décor il a 200 secondes
pour nous expliquer pourquoi la crise du
logement s'aggrave c'est le chrono de
Blacko bien sûr pour commencer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir chers Stéphane
blackovski bonsoir à vous bonsoir à
toutes et tous alors cette crise du
logement alors pour commencer cette
chronique je vous montrer vous montrer
je voudrais vous montrer le député
Martin Nadaud regardez vous allez voir
qu'il n'a pas été élu en 2022 c'est un
maçon qui a été élu vers 1850 à
l'Assemblée il venait que son bleu de
travail donc ça contribué à sa
réputation à l'Assemblée mais surtout on
lui doit ce fameux dicton quand le
bâtiment va tout va ben voilà c'est un
dicton quelque chose en ce moment le
bâtiment ça va pas du tout mais pas du
tout du tout du tout regardez les
articles qui en parlent dans la presse
la Fédération du Bâtiment estime que
100000 emplois sont menacés d'ici 2025
et puis Véronique Bellac qui est donc la
patronne de Nexity c'est le plus gros
promoteur immobilier en France Emmanuel
Macron lui avait même proposé Matignon
elle elle parle d'un choc d'une violence
folle donc résultat comme le bâtiment ne
va pas du tout en s'inquiète pour le
reste on se dit est-ce que tout ne va
pas suivre la même pente alors regardez
ça c'est les pronostics
d'une catastrophe à propos de ses crises
du logement à venir même le ministre
Olivier Klein s'inquiète à l'idée que le
logement puisse devenir une bombe
sociale alors on a 200 secondes j'en ai
déjà mangé 5 ans donc forcément je vais
devoir résumer on va donc dire que la
crise du logement elle était
sous-jacente mais on voyait pas trop
l'urgence et puis avec la guerre du
crâne va la crise elle est devenue aiguë
et donc là il y a deux images qui
permettent de résumer ce qui est en
train de se passer c'est à dire que les
taux d'intérêt sont en train de grimper
donc pour emprunter sur 20 ans en avril
c'est au-delà de 3% en moyenne la
conséquence on la connaît plein de
ménages ne peuvent plus emprunter et
donc le nombre de prêts accordés et bien
lui il suit la cour inverse il est un
peu en chuté alors que faire bon ben
déjà le gouvernement a commencé par
changer de fusil d'épaule parce que je
sais pas si vous souvenez mes premiers
janvier 2022 il avait durci les critères
d'accès au crédit immobilier mais ça
c'est avant la guerre en Ukraine parce
que maintenant forcément à Bruno Lemaire
se dit peut-être que on pourrait faire
l'inverse au contraire assouplir les
conditions crédit ça permettrait sans
doute de favoriser la demande mais on
préfère la réflexion inverse on pourrait
se dire on pourrait aussi essayer de
soutenir l'offre en allégeant par
exemple certaines réglementations dans
ce domaine je sais pas si vous souvenez
mais janvier donc de cette année Édouard
Philippe avait dit que c'était une folie
cette enfin ce qui était prévenu dans la
loi 2021 c'est-à-dire interdiction dans
les années à venir de lire de parment de
louer les passoires thermiques donc il
n'est pas le seul à le penser Véronique
Bedag dont je vous ai déjà parlé est à
peu près sur la même ligne on écoute on
s'est rendu compte qu'en Île-de-France
46% des logements qui sont aujourd'hui
loués dans le dans le secteur privé sont
des passoires thermiques donc
potentiellement ces logements risquent
de sortir du marché de la location vous
imaginez que l'effet que ça peut avoir
en Île-de-France
vous imaginez la crise qui s'annonce
donc juste avant de vous laisser
débattre et vous voyez que déjà là il y
a matière à débat je voudrais juste vous
rappeler un chiffre un classement c'est
les postes de dépenses des Français donc
on parle souvent en ce moment de
l'inflation sur l'alimentation mais
c'est loin d'être le premier poste de
dépenses le premier poste de dépenses et
là c'est une moyenne c'est pour 30 % des
budgets c'est le logement pour les
Français c'est beaucoup plus ça presque
40% pour les bas revenus donc forcément
s'il y a une crise du logement ça va
faire une créer une pression sur le truc
qui peut mettre les Français en colère
auxquels ils sont très attachés c'est le
pouvoir d'achat ça risque d'arriver
comme ça alors est-ce que la crise du
logement va être une banque sociale moi
je ne sais pas mais on a invité des
experts donc il y a des bas Julien Bayou
avant de parler d'Airbnb j'aimerais
qu'on essaye de dresser un peu un état
des lieux la crise s'aggrave on l'a
compris avec l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt est-ce que c'est pas le moment
peut-être à l'assemblée de trouver une
forme de consensus national sur le sujet
mis à part Airbnb pour dire on y va on
va faire un projet de loi on tous le
gouvernement à en faire sa priorité et
c'est ce que nous proposons depuis des
lustres parce que là on parle de la
crise du logement comme si elle était
soudaine comme si elle venait d'arriver
mais la Fédération française du bâtiment
disait c'est pas faute d'avoir prévenu
c'est pas faute que tous les premiers
février la Fondation Abbé Pierre sorte
son rapport sur le mal logement et nous
explique que malheureusement la
situation s'aggrave 4 millions de mal
logés c'est le chiffre qu'on doit
retenir mais un doublement du nombre de
sans domicile fixe depuis 20 ans la
crise s'aggrave elle est là elle
s'installe pour ma part j'ai fait partie
de collectif nous avions même créer un
ministère de la crise du logement en
disant que puisque la crise du logement
était là il fallait carrément en faire
un ministère c'était pour plaisanter
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que on
découvre pas le sujet là on a un
gouvernement qui est il est pas en place
depuis un an il est en place depuis 6
ans Emmanuel Macron a fait un deuxième
quinquennat il ne sait pas préoccupé de
logements il ne s'est pas préoccupé de
construction de logements sociaux il ne
s'est pas préoccupé d'encadrement des
loyers il s'est pas préoccupé de
rénovation thermique si bien qu'à la fin
vous avez tous les éléments qui
passionne et pour arriver à cette
explosion du poids du logement dans le
panier des ménages mais c'est le
chauffage c'est la location c'est le
crédit et moi je m'alarme quand on dit
on va faciliter le recours au crédit
mais les gens sont déjà en difficulté en
surendettement l'enjeu c'est pas de les
aider à s'endetter su de manière
supérieure c'est de pouvoir se loger
dignement et pour ça il faut construire
il faut encadrer les loyers il faut
encadrer Airbnb et il faut développer
massivement la rénovation thermique
c'est un réservoir d'emploi phénoménal
nous avons un petit sujet au projet
de 7 milliards d'euros un amendement de
7 milliards d'euros le gouvernement a
préféré l'esquiver à la faveur du Carona
3 vous savez ils peuvent réécrire des
textes 7 milliards d'euros pour que on
puisse se chauffer correctement être
indépendant du gaz russe créer des
emplois et améliorer la santé et les
climats ça a été refusé voilà vous avez
déjà bien planté le décor avec tous les
sujets mais il y a un gros débat sur la
question de disponible
est-ce que ça va pas un peu trop vite de
les interdire Stéphane
[Musique]
très nouveau ne lâche pas leur studio à
l'été parce qu'ils ont peur ils
préfèrent payer leur deux mois qui est
d'ordinaire leur permet et ça ça c'est
quand même un signal alors c'est presque
un signal fort et pas un signal faible
de quelque chose qui ne va pas qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire à très court terme sur
le sur les loyers il y a un sujet du
logement qui est multifactoriel en effet
il y a des éléments différents et des
mesures à prendre de façon globale et
parfois très forte comme l'a dit Julien
Bayou ça fait 6 ans qu'on ne parle pas
de logement aujourd'hui nous sommes tout
un tas de parlementaires à être prêt à
travailler sur cette question là et on a
un joint Olivier clair apprendre la
mesure des responsabilités du logement à
apprendre la mesure des responsabilités
qui sont les siennes parce que c'est une
bonne sociale à retardement c'est le
premier poste des ménages de dépenses
des ménages des Français on l'a dit il y
a des actions qui sont mis en place on
nous dit souvent oui mais c'est pas ça
qui règlera le tout le problème du
logement je suis d'accord parce qu'il
faudrait une PPL à 90 articles il faut
une proposition de loi à 90 articles
donc il faut bien va commencer par
quelque chose c'est ce que nous avons
proposé avec Julien ce que nous allons
que nous continuons de travailler avec
Renaissance y compris parce que c'est un
constat qui est unanime quasiment
unanime chez les députés et qui mérite
d'être actionné donc notamment sur la
question des loyers sur la question de
la spéculation immobilière sur la
question de l'adaptation du logement au
vieillissement de la population sur les
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
c'est un enjeu d'avenir c'est un enjeu
de société pour refaire société il faut
aussi pour que chacun puisse avoir un
toit sur la tête parce que c'est des
dernières années le droit de propriété a
pris l'incendante sur le droit au
logement pour tous qu'est-ce qui vous
semble le plus urgent mettre deuzuer sur
la crise du logement qu'on traverse et
qui est aigu à cause des taux d'intérêt
alors moi j'entends j'entends beaucoup
parler des jeans beaucoup parlé des
locataires de la crise du logement de la
difficulté pour les étudiants notamment
d'accéder à des logements mais j'entends
très peu parler des propriétaires
bailleurs je considère aujourd'hui que
il faut partir de la moitié de la
question et les propriétaires bailleurs
aujourd'hui personne s'est posé la
question de savoir pourquoi ils ont été
vers Airbnb personne à tout le monde dit
ici c'est par la retrait de l'argent etc
c'est pas tout à fait vrai de mon
cabinet j'ai dû voir 7 ou 800 personnes
en 2 ans et c'est pas du tout
démultipropriétaires des investisseurs
tout ce qu'on veut entendre c'est
monsieur madame tout le monde c'est des
cadres c'est des étudiants c'est des
artistes qui ont parfois des gros
problèmes avec leur locataires d'un pays
des gros problèmes de dégradation de
logement une justice qui m'était trois
quatre ans avant d'expulser ou avant
d'obtenir des choses il faut aussi
écouter ces bailleurs qui ont été versus
d'inflation qui vient durcir justement
ces conditions et faciliter les
expulsions donc ils vont pas pour votre
excuse de ne pas tenir moi qui suis
avocate
procédure pour expulser quelqu'un à
l'aise parce que vous gagnez de l'argent
avec ces procédures
donc vous représentez voilà un intérêt
je défends les deux côtés imaginez je
vous le dis vous opposez propriétaire et
locataire est-ce complètement idiot
moi quand je parlais de sherté du
chauffage je m'en fous je vous le dis
que la personne elle soit locataire ou
propriétaire je vous ai aussi bien parlé
du problème de l'endettement donc pour
des accidents propriétaires que de la
fierté des loyers donc vous avez tout de
suite vous êtes tout de suite
précisément dans un instant et moi je
voudrais sur le panneau que on part pas
là dessus c'est pas vrai il y a pas 55 %
de locataires gentils et 45% de
propriétaires méchant d'ailleurs la
plupart des propriétaires ils sont
propriétaires
occupants donc en fait il y a une infime
fraction de personnes qui sont
multipropriétaires et qui sont
d'ailleurs propriétaires d'un gros
paquet de logements dans le pays moi je
voudrais qu'on fasse non pas leurs
intérêt à eux puisque vous faites un peu
mais l'intérêt des propriétaires
occupants et des locataires et dans ce
cas là ça veut dire construire ça veut
dire encadrer les loyers ça veut dire
garantir le fait que quand il y a des
impayés et bien il y a une garantie des
impayés de loyer et non pas le fait
qu'il y a une expulsion à la fin parce
que personne n'y est déjà pas mal de
pistes sur la table ça veut dire
peut-être aussi et je pose la question
Stéphanie movitz ralentir aussi sur les
obligations de la loi climat et
résilience quand on interdit les
passoires thermiques et bah forcément on
part ce que disait Véronique Bedag de
Nexity 46 % des logements passent leur
thermique en Île-de-France forcément ça
rend chérit la pénurie alors
effectivement il y a je pense qu'on est
à un moment historique en matière de
logement pourquoi parce que il y a la
hausse des taux d'intérêts mais la
hausse des taux d'intérêt ça ne concerne
pas non plus que les accidents ça
concerne aussi beaucoup d'investisseurs
notamment institutionnels qui ou des
foncières ou autres qui ont accès enfin
qui doivent utiliser le crédit pour
justement réinvestir en matière de
logement donc aujourd'hui la
problématique c'est que le résidentiel a
un rendement extrêmement faible il faut
le savoir pourquoi il y a eu tellement
de sessions en résidentielle dans les
années 80 tout simplement parce que le
rendement était insuffisant et les
investisseurs préférés seraient orientés
vers du tertiaire où il y avait des
rendements plus importants donc
aujourd'hui les taux d'intérêt ayant
tellement augmenté ils se désintéressent
un petit peu naturellement et ça c'est
le premier sujet et sur la question du
climat sur la question du climat c'est
beaucoup d'acteurs et aussi des acteurs
du logement social qui vous disent ça va
beaucoup trop vite le zéro
artificialisation nette également qui
fait qu'on a encore plus de problèmes
pour pour construire est-ce que c'est
pas aller trop vite et trop fort je vous
pose la question vous répondez parce que
c'est ce que disent tous les font tous
les élus locaux pratiquement
cristallise cette crise qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement cette
problématique
des DPPE en matière de logement mais ça
veut pas dire
diagnostic de performance énergétique en
matière de logement ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut s'y disiez s'intéresser de ce
de ce point-là parce que c'est très
important qu'on puisse mettre en place
des logements vertueux etc la seule
chose c'est que effectivement il y a un
calendrier qui a été arrêté maintenant
ce calendrier est faux le respecter
autant que possible parce que ça
permettra aussi de réduire les charges
pour les locataires de réduire des
charges et peut-être d'augmenter un peu
le rendement pour les propriétaires et
donc ça c'est des choses intéressantes
mais pour ça il faut aussi pouvoir
bénéficier de mesure qui vont permettre
je voudrais rappeler quand même une
chose le locatif est détenu en France à
97% par des particuliers et ce sont pas
forcément des propriétaires multi multi
appartement donc ses propriétaires c'est
souvent des compléments de retraite il
faut pouvoir les accompagner et les
aider pour faire les travaux on termine
sur la question de la loi climat qui
impose des obligations peut-être trop
drastiques
il manque il manque un morceau et Julien
a expliqué tout à l'heure déjà pour
rebondir sur les premiers propos on
parle de rendement du logement moi je
considère que le logement ne doit pas
être un objet spéculatif pour faire de
l'argent et c'est là où il y a ce débat
là parce que je considère qu'on a tous
avoir un logement sur la sur la tête
avant de vouloir quand on interdit de
louer une passoire même si c'est pas
bien voilà c'est pas une erreur de le
faire trop vite c'est un enjeu
écologique et c'est un enjeu de santé
publique aussi parce que les gens qui
habitent dans des passeurs thermiques
c'est des gens qui sont confrontés à la
moisissure qui sont confrontés à des
maladies donc il est nécessaire de
lutter contre ces passoires là mais il
est aussi nécessaire que l'État engage
un fond nécessaire
c'est pas assez c'est pas suffisant et
ça marche pas très bien et c'est comme
sur Lausanne en effet attention
artificialisation net moi je suis
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut limiter
qu'on arrête de construire dans les
campagnes un peu c'est un peu ça
un petit sujet où on n'est pas forcément
d'accord à 100% avec Julien parce que je
considère qu'on peut pas appliquer la
même chose dans les villes que dans les
campagnes notamment dans les territoires
ruraux mais c'est ça c'est une question
de décret d'adaptation moi je suis
d'accord sur le fait qu'il faut limiter
la construction c'est une très bonne
chose protéger les terres agricoles
notamment en milieu rural comme chez moi
mais il manque un pied parce que c'est
pour une loi marche il faut que ça soit
sur les deux pieds il manque le pied de
l'accompagnement de l'état de la
rénovation du bâti existant parce que si
on dit on lève la construction très bien
mais faut rénover la vitesse rénovation
thermique ça coûte de l'argent c'est
l'État qui paye c'est donc le
contribuable investissement sur
l'investissement garde les regarder
comme il y a un an on était en panique
littéralement quand la Russie
je parle sous le contrôle à couper ou à
menacer de couper les livraisons de gaz
et là on s'est dit on est hyper
dépendant et nous disions ben oui mais
avec des énergies renouvelables on
serait moins dépendants et si on n'avait
pas des passoires si on en gros quand on
allume le convecteur électrique on se
retrouve à chauffer les pigeons ben on
serait moins dépendant et puis par
ailleurs c'est meilleur pour le
porte-monnaie ça l'Allemagne il a
compris ils étaient plus dépendants que
nous du gaz ils ont mis les bouchées
doubles pour être moins dépendant et
beaucoup beaucoup de rénovations nous
appelons à la création d'un service
public de la rénovation thermique qu'on
fasse les travaux à votre place la
Fédération française du bâtiment le
demande parce que c'est un emploi tous
les 10 logements rénovés les maires le
demandent les habitants le demandent
j'imagine que vous êtes d'accord et vous
aviez parlé d'un intérêt aussi puisque
bah ça fait moins de de charges de
chauffage et autres pour pour tout le
monde pourquoi ça tarde voilà nous
avions arraché 7 millions le ministre du
Logement le ministre de l'Économie la
première ministre a dit non non vraiment
c'est pas la priorité un service public
c'est posé et on posera la question à la
majorité au ministre du Logement qu'on a
eu d'ailleurs en ligne aujourd'hui qui
nous a promis de venir nous parler de
cette crise Isabelle la cerveaure regard
vous pensez que les Russes avaient
anticipé qu'il allait déstabiliser à ce
point nos économies le logement c'est la
première dépense et on est là avec des
taux d'intérêt à 3% peu plus acheter oui
parce que de toute façon le le la
politique de Vladimir Poutine et de
d'utiliser les faiblesses de nos
sociétés de nos démocraties européennes
pour nous diviser et nous affaiblir donc
à chaque fois qu'il y a un truc qui
fonctionne pas et qui a une faiblesse il
rentre dedans donc oui bien sûr et tout
ça c'est voulu et de longue date c'est
voulu c'est ce qu'on appelle la guerre
hybride qui consiste à faire la guerre à
ses voisins d'abord et ensuite au pays
occidentaux pas seulement par des moyens
militaires comme en Ukraine mais aussi
en s'appuyant sur en ayant des
cinquièmes colonnes politiques et en
utilisant les manques ou les dépendances
énergétiques des pays européens
en trafiquant enfin en essayant de
manipuler les élections
en développant des moyens de propagande
comme ça l'était avec Rochette ou bien
sûr on en reparlera tout à l'heure alors
justement qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire bah
dans l'immédiat les députés ils ont
décidé de s'attaquer à Airbnb libéré les
logements la location et bien c'est un
petit groupe de parlementaires je vous
le disais de tout bord avec une
proposition de loi qui sera déposée
début juin l'objectif c'est de supprimer
la niche fiscale en faveur de la
location de meublés tourisme qui incite
les propriétaires à louer pour des
périodes très courtes Diane Karcher
mourg a pu suivre quelques uns d'entre
vous c'était dans le 9e à Paris où les
appartements Airbnb explosent reportage
ce matin au coeur du quartier parisien
du sentier deux élus sur le terrain font
un constat devenu récurrent on est sur
un exemple typique de ce qu'aujourd'hui
il nous manque c'est 2500 mètres carrés
de bureau qui vont être transformés en
meublé touristique on l'apprend par
bouche à oreille etc on demande
simplement à pouvoir en être informé ici
comme dans de nombreux quartiers du
centre de Paris les locations Airbnb ont
petit à petit grignoter l'espace il y en
aurait plus de 40 000 dans la capitale
résultat les prix montent les logements
disponibles diminuent et les Parisiens
ne trouvent plus à se loger la ville de
Paris a décidé de réagir en modifiant
dès le mois de juin le plan local
d'urbanisme nous allons rendre public
des secteurs entiers dans lesquels nous
conseillons qu'il y a trop de meublés
touristiques et il sera interdit d'en
créer en plus tout simplement stopper la
multiplication des Airbnb assimilé c'est
aussi l'objectif d'une proposition de
loi transpartisanes elle prévoit
d'imposer les mêmes conditions de
performance énergétique au meublé
touristique colocation classique de
renforcer les pouvoirs des communes pour
en contrôler l'implantation et
d'augmenter leur fiscalité
réglementée un impératif c'est la
conviction du maire de Saint-Malo dans
sa commune il impose des quotas aux
propriétaires 12% de logements en
location courte durée dans la vieille
ville
7,5% sur le littoral seul 1696 logements
peuvent désormais être inscrits sur la
plateforme Airbnb et les propriétaires
doivent obtenir l'autorisation de la
mairie je pense que si nous ne l'avions
pas fait aujourd'hui l'ensemble du
quartier d'Intramuros serait de la
location de courte durée ça en prenait
vraiment le chemin dès qu'un logement
était à vendre il était acquis par un
investisseur qui le louait en courte
durée la ville de Saint-Malo interdite
également aux multiples propriétaires de
louer plus d'un appartement une manière
de remettre des logements sur le marché
pour les Malouins
ce qui frappe une questionnise c'est que
c'est un peu partout en fait dans dans
toutes les zones touristiques et même
au-delà dans les dans les périphéries
alors Paris vous avez fait un calcul
Julien Bayou j'ai lu le papier du monde
le troisième arrondissement de Paris
2600 offres Airbnb et seulement 55
location classique
c'est sérieux c'est si la disproportion
entre 2016 et 2020 130% d'augmentation
du nombre de mobilités de tourisme on
arrive aujourd'hui dans une situation où
les gens qui vivent sur les territoires
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre ne trouve
plus de logement on a des soignants de
l'hôpital de Bayonne qu'il était dorment
dans leur voiture on a des gens qui au
mois de juin sont mis dehors leur
appartement par leur agence immobilière
ou leurs propriétaires pour pouvoir
faire du Airbnb moi je suis et je le dis
de très droit dans les armes monsieur je
suis pas un petit touriste mais je suis
pas anti Airbnb ça fait partie de
l'économie de nos territoires sauf qu'il
faut aujourd'hui arriver à une
régulation à une remise à la fiscalité
et à permettre surtout aux gens qui font
vivre ces territoires à l'année de
pouvoir se loger et on arrive à un
plafond de verre ou même les saisonniers
n'ont pas de quoi se loger et les
patrons qui font les patrons qui du
secteur du tourisme sont démunis parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de manœuvre parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de quoi les loger donc
on arrive sur un sur tourisme il faut
réguler tout ça permettre à ceux qui
veulent louer leur chambre leur
appartement quand ils sont en vacances
de pouvoir le faire ça c'est le but
initial d'Airbnb à la base c'était ça
c'est de pouvoir louer son propre
logement quand on y était pas ou ça
charme qui n'est pas occupé aujourd'hui
on est arrivé sur ça a été dit dans le
reportage à Paris mais aussi dans les
différents territoires à des gens qui
investissent sur trois quatre cinq
appartements pour faire uniquement du
Airbnb et c'est ça que nous voulons
dénoncer et que nous voulons faire
changer maîtres quand même une captation
du marché locatif de expliquer pourquoi
de courte durée tout à l'heure de 2800
logements alors ça tout de suite c'est
un chiffre qui parle tout le monde dit
oh mon Dieu on a capté des quartiers
entiers mais il y a une chose qui est
très importante que personne ne dit on
parle essentiellement à 80 90% des
ça veut dire que ce sont des gens qui
louent leur résidence principale sans
120 jours par an 120 je pense que c'est
la loi aujourd'hui c'est applicable et
de toute façon ces gens-là j'ai envie de
vous dire comme c'est leur résidence
principale ils peuvent pas la louer à
des étudiants
si je peux juste emmener ma phrase vous
interrompre exprès quand vous êtes en
résidence principale vous ne pouvez pas
louer votre logement à des étudiants ou
à des ou à quiconque d'ailleurs c'est
votre résidence principale vous en
faites ce que vous voulez la ville de
Paris a dit c'est 120 jours c'est bien
ça fait 3800 euros 3800 euros par an de
complément de loyer pour des milliers de
Français à l'heure on parle du pouvoir
d'achat c'est très vertueux les le reste
les propriétaires quand ils
vont à Biarritz ils vont se former
120 jours par an 120 jours par an ils
ont le droit quand on voit les le
reportage que vous avez mis tout à
l'heure ce sont des bureaux avec je
voyais monsieur Grégoire qui disait on
va tout arrêter mais ce même monsieur
Grégoire
justement ce même monsieur Grégoire
c'est le même aujourd'hui les mêmes
aujourd'hui qui a autorisé des commerces
et des bureaux à bénéficier du meublé
touristique c'est aujourd'hui un
dispositif légal qu'il va changer mais
qui aujourd'hui légal on n'est pas dans
le hors la loi on peut la changer mais
aujourd'hui c'est légal 120 jours c'est
légal les commerces en transformation
c'est légal alors
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces
situations parce que vous avez des gens
qui sont les habitants d'une région
d'une ville qui sont obligées
ils sont incontestables c'est ce
d'Airbnb sur le troisième arrondissement
47% des logements mis à disposition le
sont mis par des personnes qui mettent
plusieurs logements ils sont poursuivis
par la ville dans ces cas-là
il s'agit pas de leur résidence
principale c'est du secondaire
la plupart de ces logements ne sont pas
des résidences principales mais je peux
vous garantir que ça s'est calmé mais je
vous crois pas du tout sur parole alors
écoutez vous n'avez pas en face de vous
un député écologiste et un député
socialiste je pense qu'il faut vraiment
entendre parce que dans cette position
nous avons horizon il y a des députés
Renaissance qui vont défendre Christophe
Plassard qui est la majorité et je peux
vous dire qu'on se combat sur à peu près
tout sauf là-dessus parce qu'il est
député de Sharon maritime et de autour
de l'île d'Oléron et c'est une
catastrophe vous avez le sénateur Max
Brisson du Pays Basque je pense que il
n'ya
c'est un tsunami silencieux de
disparition ou plutôt de fuite du
logement pérenne vers des meubles
touristiques parce que c'est plus
lucratif et pas assez encadré mais nous
proposons d'encadrer je comprends que ça
va vous faire alors expliquez-nous ce
que vous proposez parce qu'il y a une
niche fiscale c'est ça qui c'est quoi la
niche fiscale on ne paye pas d'impôts
quand on fait du Airbnb pardonnez-moi
le même appartement ou proposer
normalement la taxation normale
mais selon le même appartement qui
produit des revenus fonciers volontaires
ben vous êtes imposé sur les revenus
fonciers si vous le mettez en meublé
touristique vous êtes moins imposé en
gros abattement
d'abattement sur les meublés classés et
uniquement 30% pour le logement
permanent et c'est ça c'est ce
déséquilibre là et en plus il y a un
plafond d'incitation à faire du meublé
de courte durée jusqu'à 172000 euros par
votre meublé et vous avez 71%
d'abattement c'est irréel c'est jusqu'à
combien de temps un an
cinq jours en fait pour résumer un petit
peu en sous 30 jours c'est de la courte
durée et vous pouvez faire à l'année
évidemment vous le pouvez renouveler
l'abattement fiscal jusqu'à un an
en fait 71% d'abattement Stark sur les
loyers que vous percevez qui sont pas
des loyers parce que c'est du meuble
touristique mais par rapport à des
loyers en bail trois 6 9 classique vous
avez un abattement qui palu jusqu'à 71%.
donc on est ensemble des loyers des
recettes des revenus alors c'est que 30%
sur le permanent donc c'est ce
déséquilibrant qu'il faut remettre qu'il
faut remettre à niveau des niches
fiscales et parce que ça incite en effet
les gens à faire du meublé de tourisme
parce qu'en trois mois il gagne déjà
plus que en 12 et en plus ils sont
défiscalisés à 71 % il y a des gens qui
font vraiment je sais pas moi trois
quatre cinq location Airbnb en
permanence en secondaire comme ça pour
au fond presque une activité de rentier
ça existe
parfaitement vrai ce que vous dites sur
la fiscalité je vous rejoins 100% c'est
pas normal qu'on n'est pas la même
fiscalité très bien je suis d'accord
avec vous il y a des villes
effectivement où on peut faire ce qu'on
veut on peut en louer même 15 ou 20 mais
moi je dis une chose qui est très simple
j'ai vu votre projet de loi j'étais
surpris de l'article de qu'est-ce qui
nous dit l'article 2 il dit désormais il
y a des communes qui pourront
restreindre un petit peu la
réglementation un petit peu comme à
Paris c'est exactement ce qu'a fait
Saint-Malo en 2018 il y a déjà un texte
qui existe l'article 131-9 du Code de la
Construction je vois pas ce que une
nouvelle article vient ajouter il existe
déjà depuis quelques années comment
ces villes qui sont très seules qui se
battent pour le logement des personnes
qui habitent sur leur territoire elles
sont attaquées elles sont attaquées par
déjà un outil pour réglementer en
justice de règlement
Oléron peuvent être attaqués demain par
Airbnb Biarritz le risque de l'être
prochainement et nous l'enjeu pour nous
parlementaire c'est le sécuriser la
situation de ces mérites et depuis votre
regard
studios ces deux pièces dans les grandes
villes mais pas seulement est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée notre regard c'est
qu'il faut effectivement une régulation
il est pas normal que il y ait une
emprise de cette manière à travers
Airbnb d'abord parce que ça fait de la
concurrence aussi aux autres hôtels ce
qui est pas non plus forcément une
mauvaise
mais la problématique quand même c'est
de se dire qu'est-ce qui se passe
des impôts embauche des personnes font
respectent des réglementations de
sécurité
qui se pose c'est notamment des
immeubles de bureau qui sont obsolètes
je dis bien des immeubles de bureau
obsolètes et là effectivement que ce
soit ce type de bien qui puisse être
transformé en meublé touristique c'est
une chose et ça ne retire pas
d'offre complémentaires au niveau
logement donc ça il peut y avoir des
réflexions qui peuvent se porter sur
l'immobilier de bureau qui est obsolète
et qui aujourd'hui sur lequel il y a
plus de marché tout simplement plus on
va s'arrêter là on va suivre évidemment
cette proposition de là il y a une date
9 juin on n'a pas compris il y a une ou
deux propositions de loi un appel commun
avec différents parlementaires qui ont
été cités par Max par par Julien Bayou
avec Max Bresson et Christophe Plassard
et moi-même et puis on a aussi convaincu
à force les uns les autres de monter au
créneau la majorité et le groupe
renaissance de travailler sur ce sujet
là et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
travaillé sur un premier texte plus
court avec Anna et le meurt qui sera
coporté de façon transpartizane sur le
modèle de la porte
ce texte aboutissent et trouve une
majorité une première partie du texte et
nous ce qu'on appelle c'est que ça
continue compare du logement pendant les
prochains mois pendant les prochaines
années pour régler ce problème là donc
le gouvernement français
ce soir Conseil national de la
rénovation sur le logement mardi et
quelque chose me dit que voilà ça va
monter en puissance merci Monsieur Merci
d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous restez
évidemment avec moi Isabelle Lasserre
dans une dizaine de minutes les partis
pris de nos affranchis vous dévoyés ils
sont fin prêts ce soir l'économie avec
Thomas l'estavel quand le Green Deal
européen profite au chinois
l'international avec Vincent le carnage
au Soudan au bord de la guerre totale et
puis Stéphane idpierre dans Bourbon
Express nous raconte comment les
communistes ont remporté une bataille
dans l'hémicycles aujourd'hui mais
d'abord on va plonger dans votre livre
Isabelle Lasserre Macron Poutine les
liaisons dangereuses vous les analysez
avec finesse mais vous les analysez
aussi sans concession depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine pourquoi la France
est toujours heurté au mur rouge du
Kremlin regardez c'est dans l'invitation
de Marco pommier puis on en parle
ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Isabelle la serre
c'est pour parler d'une relation
tumultueuse ambiguë celle d'Emmanuel
Macron et de Vladimir Poutine l'histoire
d'une partie d'échec perdue d'avance
Emmanuel Macron a sur jamais l'influence
qu'il peut avoir sur un ancien agent du
KGB qui mieux que vous Isabelle Lasserre
pour nous raconter cette liaison
diplomatique vous l'ancienne
correspondante à Moscou pour Le Figaro
spécialiste des questions
internationales dans votre dernier livre
voudrait c'est un terrible réquisitoire
contre la politique russe d'Emmanuel
Macron un bilan aux allures de coquille
vide et pourtant en 2017 le président
français avait fait forte impression
après son élection sous les ordres de
Versailles il recevait en grande pompe
le maître du Kremlin évidemment je suis
impressionnée par Versailles et parce
que cela reflète la grandiosité de la
France et de son histoire deux ans plus
tard sous le soleil de Brégançon les
deux dirigeants apparaissent proches
malgré leur divergence sur la Syrie ou
encore l'Ukraine la Russie est
européenne
très profondément et nous croyons dans
cette Europe qui va de Lisbonne et
Vladivostok face à la guerre Emmanuel
Macron tente la diplomatie du coup de
fil 21 conversations pour amener
Vladimir Poutine à la raison jusqu'au
bout le président français a cru pouvoir
influencer le maître du Kremlin à
l'image de cette rencontre à bonne
distance quelques jours seulement avant
que l'Ukraine ne se réveille sous les
bombes tu as pris une décision
historique qui va nous séparer pendant
longtemps je n'aurais aucune faiblesse
je sais que zellenski est Héré dans son
bunker comme Hitler soit je rase
l'Ukraine soit je coupe sa tête
politique le président français qui se
veut médiateur dans le conflit ukrainien
une posture critiquée par nos alliés de
l'Europe de l'Est sans oublier ses
expressions qui ont fait bondir vos
lotski il ne faut pas humilier la Russie
alors Isabelle Lasserre vous dénoncez-le
en même temps diplomatique d'Emmanuel
Macron soutenir l'Ukraine tout
emménageant Vladimir Poutine mais cette
troisième voie n'est-elle pas celle de
la paix
réponse Isabelle Lasserre cette
troisième voie à laquelle tient tant le
président français écoutez en théorie
l'idée d'une troisième voie par exemple
comme ce qui essaie de faire la France
entre la Chine et les États-Unis
pourquoi pas le problème c'est que le
concept de 3e voie est donc de en même
temps
fonctionne assez mal en politique
internationale quand on est dans au
milieu d'une grosse crise ou d'une
guerre comme aujourd'hui car finalement
comment en fait
continuer à parler bon il ne parle plus
Emmanuel Macron pour l'instant Vladimir
Poutine a mis de la fait pendant
longtemps comment continuer à parler
avec
Vladimir Poutine après boutcha après
tous les crimes de guerre qui ont été
commis après sa radicalisation après ses
mensonges et après son refus absolu de
faire le moindre le moindre compromis et
surtout comment ne pas choisir en fait
entre un pouvoir qui est devient
totalitaire
dirigé par un criminel de à la tête d'un
clan mafieux et une jeune démocratie
l'Ukraine avec un président démocrate
qui défend beaucoup plus fort d'ailleurs
et beaucoup plus haut que la plupart des
pays de l'Union européenne les valeurs
de la démocratie et de l'Europe comment
ne pas choisir entre les deux alors
justement on va revenir sur ces en même
temps au total il y a eu 21
conversations téléphoniques entre le
président français et Vladimir Poutine
alors toutes nos servi à rien il y en a
eu trop trop de conversations ça nuit à
la réputation à l'image de la France
voilà en fait au début Emmanuel Macron a
eu raison de téléphoner à Vladimir
Poutine
volody mirzelenski lui-même le lui
demandait il n'était pas sûr à l'époque
que son pays son armée tienne que ce que
la société soit aussi résiliente que ça
il pensait que il était possible que la
guerre dure assez peu de temps et
qu'elle se termine par des négociations
ensuite au fur et à mesure qui ont été
commis les crimes de guerre c'est l'axe
est devenu très très compliqué c'est à
dire à la fois la radicalisation de
Vladimir Poutine et la constatation
qu'en fait aucune des conversations de
avec Vladimir Poutine des bouches sur
quoi que ce soit
à la limite c'est pas très grave on peut
parler à Vladimir Poutine les pays de
l'Est disent que ça ça légitime en fait
un dictateur mais on peut continuer à
parler comme lorsque Emmanuel Macron
avait par exemple essayé de réunir les
dirigeants américains et iraniens pour
essayer de faire renaître l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien ça n'a pas marché
il n'y a pas eu de dégâts collatéraux le
problème avec cette crise avec ce
dossier c'est qu'au bout de plusieurs
mois ça a provoqué une incompréhension
chez nos partenaires de l'Europe
d'Europe orientale qui eux sont à la
frontière de la Russie ont tous presque
tous ont éprouvés par l'Armée rouge par
le passé par l'Armée rouge et donc se
sentent directement menacé par par la
Russie donc moi il a pas compris ça
plutôt le président
qu'il fallait cesser cette tête
infructueux comment vous l'expliquez
écoutez je pense que jusqu'au bout le
président français a cru d'une part il
croit beaucoup dans les relations
interprétiennes interpersonnelles il
avait eu la même méthode avec Donald
Trump et il est possible qu'il ait en
partie la même méthode avec le président
chinois chez greenping il a cru que à
force de de conviction de travail
d'effort il pourrait influencer au moins
à la marge Vladimir Poutine et surtout
il a cru mais ça c'est un petit peu un
travers français vous savez la France
est un pays en fait qui voyage en
première classe avec un billet de
deuxième classe ça a toujours été comme
France ce surestime la France
elle sait faire des choses que les
autres ne savent pas faire mais en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui avec tous les
rapports de de force qui qui change dans
le monde depuis plusieurs années et qui
changent de plus en plus vite avec
l'affaiblissement économique de la
France avec ses problèmes sociaux avec
plein de choses c'est vrai que la France
n'a pas l'influence seule pour
influencer Vladimir Poutine alors encore
une fois n'est pas c'est Vladimir
Poutine plus un allié quand même qui est
l'Iran plus quand même toute une partie
du monde d'ailleurs du parti du monde
qui soit le soutien soit
au minimum veut rester neutre alors vous
vous racontez bien toute cette
diplomatie française due en même temps
il y a il y a les mots qui ont blessé
Hélène ski quand Macron a dit ne pas
humilier la Russie parler de garantie de
sécurité pour la Russie puis il y a les
mots qu'il n'a pas dit et qu'il a
finalement dit c'est-à-dire il faut que
l'Ukraine gagne il faut que la Russie
perde je souhaite la défaite de Vladimir
Poutine il a fini par lâcher ça il a
fini par le dire en février 2023
c'est-à-dire un an après le début de la
guerre et tout le monde attendait qu'il
le dit sous la pression ces mots-là
l'Ukraine doit gagner ça implique
vous la Russie doivent perdre parce que
il a il a eu plusieurs évolutions
pendant la guerre Emmanuel Macron et là
jusqu'à fin décembre il disait ok
l'Ukraine doit gagner mais il n'arrivait
pas à dire la Russie la Russie doit
perdre donc il a mis effectivement très
très longtemps et c'est ce en fait cette
absence de de en fait de politique
claire dès le début qui ont en fait jeté
une espèce de doute chez nos personnes
qui créent les dangers dans la relation
au sein même de l'Europe on a vu parce
que sur le fond parce que les critiques
que je formule à l'encontre d'Emmanuel
Macron sont en partie injuste parce que
sur le fond la politique de la France
est claire vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine la
France aide l'Ukraine à la fois
militairement politiquement
économiquement des réfugiés également
une merveilleusement bien des réfugiés
elle fournit des armes quand même qui
font la différence sur le terrain en
livrant les chars légers AMX Emmanuel
Macron a ouvert la porte à d'autres
livraisons de char plus lourd donc c'est
vrai que la France n'a pas d'ambiguïté
dans son soutien à l'Ukraine ce sont des
petites phrases d'Emmanuel Macron jeter
surtout prononcé en fait à des moments
enfin beaucoup trop tôt c'est-à-dire
qu'Emmanuel Macron souvent se projette
dans l'après-guerre alors on en parlera
peut-être après de ce qui concerne ce
qui va en parler comme la paix mais le
fait de se projeter dans la quand il dit
par exemple il faut des garanties de
sécurité pour la Russie c'est pas
aujourd'hui il parle de sécurité de à
l'avenir
évidemment quand on construira la paye
il s'agit pas de de d'appuyer sur la
tête des Russes de dire que la Russie
doit disparaître de la surface de la
Terre mais au moment où vous ne les
prénoms ça passe mal parce qu'on
attendrait de lui qu'ils disent il faut
des garanties de sécurité pour l'Ukraine
le pays qui est attaqué et envahi par le
par la Russie alors c'est un livre sur
la relation que vous chroniquez que vous
observez au jour le jour et donc c'est
un livre sur le regard que chacun porte
sur l'autre et alors le regard de
Poutine sur Macron c'est compliqué
Macron shake le petit Macron il y a dû
mépris il y a une forme aussi
d'humiliation de Poutine vous dites ça
n'est pas du tout sa tasse de votre cas
c'est le maillon faible de l'Europe
Macron pour Poutine alors le maillon
faible c'est-à-dire un moment donné à
partir de Brégançon en fait Vladimir
Poutine avait plutôt misé sur François
Fillon ou Marine Le Pen de candidats qui
partagaient davantage qui avait beaucoup
plus de proximité vis-à-vis du Kremlin
que Emmanuel Macron donc effectivement
c'était pas sa tasse de vodka
ilhumilie il a humilié encore bien plus
fort
Angela Merkel vous souvenez en fait elle
a une phobie des chiens de la Merkel il
l'a reçu une fois avec son labrador pour
pour l'instabiliser en fait sur mon
n'existe pas en français mais ce que je
veux dire il méprise absolument tous les
leaders européens d'ailleurs il méprise
en général parce que quand Macron un
rapprochement d'une certaine façon
d'architecture de sécurité et de ramener
d'une certaine façon
la Russie vers l'Europe là c'est une
forme à la fois d'incompréhension avec
les pays de l'est évidemment mais aussi
avec la Russie qui est l'Europe non la
Russie Vladimir Poutine sa politique
bien sûr c'est de diviser complètement
l'Europe et de l'affaiblir il ne croit
pas en Europe il pense qu'elle va
s'effondrer à la fois pour des raisons
économiques et surtout pour des raisons
en fait de société il considère que les
pays européens et d'ailleurs
particulièrement la France sont peuplées
de transsexuels qu'il n'y a plus que des
homosexuels une immigration absolument
incontrôlée
cet Occident cette vision d'un oxydant
complètement décadent qui se sont lui
qui selon lui va finir par manger les
sociétés démocratiques de l'intérieur et
alors il ne respecte absolument pas
de la démocratie il a le plus grand
mépris c'est facile de mépriser les
dirigeants européens pour Vladimir
Poutine lui reste au pouvoir ça fait 20
ans qu'il est au pouvoir et il a affaire
avec des dirigeants qui au mieux on
demanda quand Emmanuel Macron mais en
général partent au bout de 5 ans ou 6
ans dans dans d'autres pays donc en fait
lui reste et les dirigeants européens
aussi dans le livre c'est que vous ne
vous arrêtez pas du tout Emmanuel Macron
mais vous revenez à tous les présidents
français depuis le général de Gaulle et
au fond à vous lire on se dit d'autres
présidents aujourd'hui aurait eu
exactement la même diplomatie Emmanuel
Macron parce qu'au fond cette relation
franco-rue cette amitié ancienne aux
racines profondes explique tout oui
alors c'est l'amitié et c'est aussi
l'oppositionnement géostratégique de de
la France alors l'amitié c'est
effectivement il y a une relation un peu
romantique entre la France et la Russie
russophilie R à la fois parmi les élites
et parmi certains militaires date depuis
très très longtemps cette cette relation
romantique et il y a une conviction chez
les Français que ces deux anciens
empires partagent le même amour pour les
lettres la culture une espèce de culture
supérieure sans doute le pense-t-il et
il y a aussi après d'autres raisons qui
tiennent plus particulièrement en fait à
la position de la France donc pays qui
possède la bombe nucléaire donc il y a
une position très particulière en Europe
et un siège au Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU et qui depuis 1966 au moment où de
Gaulle a quitté le commandement intégré
de l'OTAN
les élites essaient de maintenir cette
position
particulière de de la France Emmanuel
Macron veut en fait l'appliquer aussi à
l'Europe et qui
implique une prise de distance en tout
cas une distance vis-à-vis des
États-Unis alors dans certains partis
politiques c'est carrément un Henri par
un entier américainisme qui est quand
même ce n'est pas le cas d'Emmanuel
Macron qui n'est pas lui pas entier
américain mais il veut que l'Europe
existe de manière stratégique et en fait
toute sa politique étrangère est
organisée autour de ça Isabelle d'un
tout petit mot hier vous étiez
chroniqueuse sur ce qui s'est passé avec
cette annonce cette drôle d'annonce même
un peu épisode mystérieux dit Catherine
Colona la ministre de des Affaires
étrangères françaises avec cette attaque
présumée de drones sur le Kremlin on a
vu les images sur les télévisions russes
sur des chaînes russes reléguées sur
Instagram impossible que ce soit les
Ukrainiens comme le prétendent les
Russes écoutez je pense qu'il y a
plusieurs scénarios en général les
Ukrainiens quand les Ukrainiens
attaquent sur le sol russe il soit il le
revendique soit il laisse entendre que
ça pourrait être là le le le
déni est vraiment enfin le nom est
absolument clair de la part de
volodières
ça peut être l'opposition russe et ça
peut être aussi une mise en scène de
Vladimir Poutine qui est quand même le
grand maître de dans l'art d'effectuer
ce type de mise en scène pour se
fomenter un attentat alors là l'attentat
personne n'y croit c'est pas deux petits
drones qui vont percer les qui vont
réussir à assassiner l'avenir petite
alors qu'il est sans doute dans son
bunker caché ailleurs mais mais
forcément au Kremlin mais si d'aventure
les propos de l'ancien président de
mitrine mvdf ont été assez durs en
disant que maintenant il voulait
l'élimination physique de volody
merzelency c'est ce qu'ils avaient prévu
d'ailleurs au début de la guerre alors
est-ce que ça
c'est les prémices d'une opération russe
en tout cas voilà Moscou parle de
représailles on peut craindre le pire
pour les Ukrainiens on va suivre ça
grâce à vous dans sa vogue sur LCP
Isabelle mais il faut lire Macron
Poutine les liaisons dangereuses aux
éditions de l'Observatoire ça commence
par un texte passionnant 1937 de
l'historien Emmanuel Berle et tout était
déjà dit je renvoie nos lecteurs à cette
inkipit comme on dit allez c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris ils vont vous faire réagir
bienvenue à vous les amis Thomas
l'estavel pour l'économie Vincent Hugo
pour l'international c'est à vous dans
quelques instants bonsoir à tous les
deux mais on commence comme chaque soir
par Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
pas Stéphanie Despierre bonsoir
Stéphanie journée difficile pour le
gouvernement oui Myriam Carlo position
les communistes spécifiquement ont
réussi à faire adopter une de leurs
propositions de loi il s'agit de la
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
alors c'est un combat de la gauche
depuis plusieurs mois qui a abouti ce
matin le gouvernement était clairement
contre car le texte abroche complètement
l'obligation à vaccinale contre le covid
pour le personnel médical le texte a été
adopté à 157 voix pour 137 contre toute
l'opposition les républicains le
rassemblement national compris a soutenu
les communistes face à des députés de la
majorité présidentielle qui n'étaient
pas assez nombreux dans l'hémicycle
c'est une victoire pour les élus
d'outre-mer en pointent contre cette
vaccination obligatoire pour les
soignants nous avons la vie de la HAS
qui ne considère que l'obligation
vaccinale n'a plus lieu d'être et du
coup on fait un peu le bilan en fait de
cette période-là ayant on corrige et
puis en abroge la loi parce que la loi
n'a plus de justification alors
l'argument qui est évoqué par le
gouvernement c'est de dire oui mais si
jamais là il y a une nouvelle un nouveau
virus ou etc mais on revient devant le
Parlement
alors en fait le gouvernement a déjà
décidé de réintégrer les soignants ce
sera effectivement le 15 mai mais
l'exécutif voulait se garder la
possibilité de réactiver cette
obligation vaccinelle en cas de
nouvelles épidémie alors après le vote à
l'assemblée et surtout Twitter le
ministre de la Santé a déploré un
mauvais signal il écrit le complotisme
la emporté sur la science lors des
débats l'assemblée la vaccination est
une arme de protection massive mais les
oppositions ont décidé d'envoyer un
message regrettable aux soignants alors
attention Myriam cette proposition de
loi n'est pas définitivement adoptée
elle n'en est qu'à la première étape de
son parcours législatif donc dans une
liste parlementaire il y a plein de
propositions de loi il y avait une autre
bataille compliquée pour le gouvernement
c'est EDF oui et là le débat était sur
le point de se terminer il y a quelques
minutes mais il s'est interrompu pour la
pose dîner et là encore le gouvernement
risque d'être mis en échec cette
proposition de loi s'oppose au
démantèlement d'EDF alors le
gouvernement conteste tout projet de
démantèlement il a abandonné Hercule un
projet très controversé
mais les communistes ont aussi intégré
un deuxième volet à cette proposition de
loi pas exactement liée au statut
d'oddesse mais au prix de l'électricité
ils veulent élargir le fameux bouclier
tarifaire aux petites entreprises aux
artisans aux commerçants notamment les
boulangers et c'est ça qui a donné lieu
au débat les plus intenses cet
après-midi
ce n'est pas vrai votre bouclier
énergétique c'est un bouclier en carton
c'est une passoire et c'est même et
c'est même et c'est même en plus un
mille-feuille bureaucratique
qui fait que nos artisans nos
commerçants passent des heures et des
heures à remplir des papiers pour
pouvoir peut-être avoir droit à quelques
centaines d'euros d'aide les boulangers
nous les avons accompagnés comme les TPE
comme les PME nous continuerons à le
faire mais attention à des dispositifs
dont je le répète
anticonstitutionnel un sécure
juridiquement qui mettront des mois à
être négocié et qui coûteront à l'état
une fortune
une fortune selon le gouvernement cela
coûterait 11 milliards d'euros qui va
payer EDF ou l'état c'est la question
que quand présidentielle a posé toute
l'après-midi à l'opposition de gauche
ils estiment que ce texte va affaiblir
EDF et non pas le protéger comme le
veulent les communistes le ministre a
clairement dit ne votez pas à cette loi
et on a assisté à partir de 19h à une
course contre la montre les députés de
la majorité et tentait de ralentir
clairement le débat pour éviter que le
vote se passe avant la pause-dinée ils
ont fait des rappels au règlement ils
ont même tenté de changer le titre de
cette loi et ils sont parvenus en tout
cas à retarder le verdict puisque le
vote n'aura lieu que dans la soirée
merci beaucoup Stéphanie c'était très
très clair Thomas l'estavel on enchaîne
avec vous bonsoir à vous vous nous dites
que la transition écologique de l'Europe
le fameux Green Deal européen va tourner
au casse-tête tourne déjà au casse-tête
à cause des Chinois oui encore eux les
chinois alors vient de se tenir à
Copenhague au Danemark le salon wine du
rock pardon qui rassemble un peu tout le
gratin de la filière éolienne avec des
boîtes comme EDF engie et l'heure on
était effectivement pas à la fête avec
l'inflation des matières premières déjà
mais surtout effectivement cette
concurrence chinoise qui commence à
miner le secteur alors le leader
historique des éoliennes c'est un danois
Vestas il est en train de se faire
rattraper à grands pas par un chinois
qu'on connaît peu en Europe qui
s'appelle Goldwin et qui risque de le
dépasser dès cette année il faut dire
que Pékin met le paquet sur l'éolien les
prises de commandes ont bondi de 70% en
Chine l'an dernier et en Europe on est
loin de ces chiffres évidemment comme
nous on est dans la course ou pas
l'Union européenne l'Union européenne se
veut volontariste effectivement
puisqu'on sait que le Green Deal dont
vous avez parlé et volontariste donc la
Commission vise 42% d'énergie
renouvelable dans le mix énergétique
d'ici à 2030 et ça ça équivaut à peu
près à doubler la cadence d'installation
des éoliennes sur le vieux continent
dans les années qui viennent donc à
priori bonne nouvelle mais le X c'est
que les équipements tirés ne suivent pas
notamment au niveau logistique et que
finalement c'est commandes ris
bénéficier à leurs concurrent et
notamment au chinois alors les
commissaires européens c'est un peu
l'ironie ils le reconnaissent eux-mêmes
puisque le projet de décarbonation
stipule qu'au moins 40% de la demande de
l'Union européenne en technologie propre
donc les éoliennes doit être satisfaite
par des entreprises européennes mais ce
que ça veut dire en creux c'est que
quand même les 60 autres pour cent vont
bénéficier à des entreprises étrangères
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire alors
déjà on l'a souvent dit mais l'Europe a
toujours été trop naïve et il faut
qu'elle cesse de l'être elle accorde des
subventions alors si on prend l'exemple
des véhicules électriques elle accorde
des subventions quelle que soit
l'origine des véhicules quelle que soit
le lieu où ils ont été fabriqués alors
qu'en Chine mais aussi aux États-Unis
uniquement c'est fabriqué sur le sol
effectivement alors on peut déjà se
calquer sur ce type de politique en
fonction de la réciprocité et nous
serons moins les dindons de la farce
après il y a une question aussi de
réalisme logistique il faut revoir le
calendrier de la décarbonation pour
s'assurer que les industriels européens
peuvent suivre le rythme et là c'est à
la fois dans les éoliennes mais aussi
l'automobile le bâtiment etc et puis
enfin nous devons mettre un peu de
protection dans les appels d'offres sur
les marchés publics donc le Green Deal
c'est bon pour la planète mais il faut
aussi protéger les entreprises et les
emplois sortir de la naïveté une bonne
fois pour toute merci beaucoup Thomas on
enchaîne avec vous Vincent vous vouliez
revenir sur cette forme de guerre
presque le mot n'est pas de trop au
Soudan et oui c'est l'histoire
desespérément banale d'un pays plongé
dans le chaos par la voracité de dessous
d'argalonnés par l'insatiable appétit de
pouvoir d'un duo de tyrannosa treillis
désormais ennemi c'est aussi celle
guerre plus originale d'une dystopie de
notre temps au clair d'une utopie qui
vire à l'aigre au printemps 2019 le
Soudan parvient à secouer le jeu du
despotisme sur fond d'insurrection
citoyenne les caïdes de l'armée et
vinstallent Omar El Bechir qui en 3dc
aura relégué l'ancien condominium
anglo-égyptien au rang de dictatures
militaro islamiste 30 mois plus tard le
tandem que dis-je l'association de
malfaiteurs que forme Abdel Fatah
Alboran et Mohamed Hamdan d'agglo
s'aborde au un putsch l'élan
démocratiques insufflé par une société
civile d'une admirable pugnacité le
premier Alboran prend les reines d'un
conseil de souveraineté le second mieux
connu sous le surnom de hémati régent à
ses côtés une puissante milice la force
de soutien rapide dont les cadres ont
orchestré jadis l'implacable répression
de la région rebelle du Darfour alors
qu'est-ce qui a fracturé ce tandem on va
passer sur le prétexte invoqué les
modalités d'intégration de la soldatesse
que des Métis au sein des forces armées
le vrai motif le voici la volonté
d'accéder au statut de seul maître à
bord du rafios soudanais quitte à
précipiter celui-ci sur les récifs de la
guerre totale à coups de redsairiens et
de combat de rue à l'arme lourdes de
caïmans dans le même Mario on connaît la
rengaine qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
comment rayer tout ça alors d'abord il
faut savoir que ce sont les civils qui
payent la note et qu'elle est salée des
morts par centaines des blessés par
milliers et des centaines de milliers
d'hommes de femmes d'enfants condamnés à
l'exode à l'exil à une perdu vers
l’égypte le Tchad l'Éthiopie la
République centrafricaine ou le Soudan
du Sud et puis en dépit de Trêves au
citron peu ce qui éphémère la loi des
armes entrave l'acheminement des vivres
et du matériel médical sont gêner que
moins de 20% des hôpitaux ou
dispensaires de Carrefour fonctionnent
encore qu'un cas et qu'avant même cette
éruption de violence a survit d'un tiers
des 46 millions de soudanais dépendaient
de l'aide humanitaire internationale on
peut ou pas à éviter ce carnage on l'ONU
si emploi vainement tout comme avec plus
ou moins d'ardeurs l'Union africaine la
Ligue arabe Liga d'une institution
régionale l'Europe les États-Unis
l'Arabie Saoudite l'Egypte mais voilà
trop de médiateurs tuent toutes
médiation d'autant que certains de ces
acteurs masquent mal leur calcul le
Caire et son maréchal président Alicia
soutiennent Alboran les Émirats penchent
pour émetti les Saoudiens prince de
l'équivoque maintiennent de faire au feu
tout comme la Russie de Poutine qui est
guidée depuis des lustres par une
obsession installée dans le coin de Port
Soudan une base navale précieux balcon
sur la mer le Kremlin ménage Alboran
tandis que les mercenaires de la maison
Wagner laquelle a investi dès 2017 dans
les mineurs locales livre ta émetti
kalachnikov et missile solaire portable
alors il y a une certitude pour terminer
l'embrasement s'il perdure ne saurait
être circonscrit au seul territoire
soudanais car il menace un voisinage
instable allusion à l'afflude migrants
vers des États fragiles mais aussi au
risque d'attiser les braises de
rébellion armées encline au confins du
Tchad et de la Centrafrique a joué à
saute frontière les histoires de putsch
finissent mal mon Général merci
bon une réaction rapidement Isabelle
même le Soudan ce petit pays là
n'échappe pas aux ambitions de la
réussite oui mais alors je pense qu'on
peut saluer là le l'opération
d'évacuation menée par les forces armées
françaises notamment les forces
spéciales qui ont sorti de l'enfer mille
personnes et qui ont en fait évacué de
manière absolument magnifique les
expatriés y compris non français qui
avait été en fait
laissé par leur gouvernement même les
Etats-Unis et même le Royaume-Uni avait
évacué leur diplomate mais pas les profs
par exemple et c'était une opération
très difficile à mener très dangereuse
quand même et c'est un savoir-faire en
fait ça s'est très très bien passé et
c'est un savoir-faire que assez peu de
place
arrive à l'Assemblée la semaine
prochaine et on en reparlera merci à
tous merci messieurs merci Stéphanie et
merci Isabelle Macron Poutine
les liaisons dangereuses c'est-à-dire
aux éditions de l'Observatoire très
belle soirée documentaire qui commence
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien bien sûr à
demain
[Musique]